♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden today spoke with
allies and partners
about the situation in Ukraine.
Next he'll speak with
Republicans.
[ Laughter ]
After the U.S. offered
over the weekend to evacuate
Ukrainian President Volodymyr
Zelenskyy -- excuse me --
amid the Russian invasion,
Zelenskyy reportedly said,
"The fight is here.
I need ammunition, not a ride."
Oh, man, how badly does Biden
wish that quote was his?
[ Laughter ]
It's like Zelenskyy said, "Come
with me if you want to live."
[ Laughter ]
If Zelenskyy gets to fight
on top of a train,
he's officially living
Biden's best life.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm the Amtrak guy!"
During his keynote speech
on Saturday at CPAC,
former President Trump said that
the country has
"lost its self-confidence
under President Biden."
Well, of course.
We all had more self-confidence
under you.
Do you know how affirming it is
to be smarter
than the president?
[ Laughter ]
Waking up every day with a jump
in my step.
[ Laughter ]
In his soon-to-be-released book,
former President Trump's
Attorney General William Barr
said, "Trump cared only about
one thing -- himself.
Country and principle
took second place."
I don't know, dude. Second?
[ Laughter ]
I think country took fifth place
and principle broke its leg
and had to be shot.
[ Laughter ]
"We can't save principle."
In the same book, Barr
criticized Trump and said,
"People are worthwhile to Trump
only as a means to his ends,
as utensils."
Said Trump, "That's a lie.
I've never used a utensil
in my life."
[ Laughter ]
Ahead of tomorrow's
State of the Union address,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
is lifting the chamber's
mask mandate, which is
concerning to many House members
who still need them
for attention.
[ Laughter ]
A Ukrainian brewery
has reportedly switched
from producing craft beers to
making Molotov cocktails
to help fight
the Russian military.
Though, if you really want to
slow down the Russians,
just give them the craft beer.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, I felt like I ate
a loaf of bread."
[ Laughter ]
"Pumpernickel?"
Lawmakers in Florida last week
passed the so-called
"don't say gay" bill, which
prohibits classroom discussions
about sexual orientation
or gender identity.
Pretty soon,
a Florida school day
is just going to be seven hours
of quiet time.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Nothing more ironic than
when the "quiet time" punch line
gets the quietest response.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe they were honoring it.
New York Mayor Eric Adams
announced yesterday that
beginning next week,
the city will no longer
require vaccine passports
at restaurants,
which is great news for all the
restaurants who already stopped
checking them three weeks ago.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a dog house
that was struck by a meteorite
sold last week for $44,000.
Even crazier, it sold on Zillow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
President Biden tonight
delivered his first
State of the Union address,
and thank God he got that
Supreme Court justice in,
'cause there was not much else
to talk about.
[ As Biden ]
Uh, I think there's a new
"Batman" movie this week.
[ Laughter ]
The New York Times
published a report yesterday
that U.S. officials
are currently debating
Russian President Vladimir
Putin's grip on reality.
In related news, Putin just
ordered troops into Hogwarts.
[ Laughter ]
When asked by a reporter
at a Black History Month
event yesterday
if Americans should be worried
about nuclear war,
President Biden said no.
Yeah, come on.
Putin isn't gonna bomb
the only people
still supporting him.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
was asked if Americans
should be worried about
nuclear war, and he said no.
But then the CDC said yes,
and the FDA said,
"We'll let you know
in four to six weeks,"
so I don't know
what's gonna happen.
Officials in Ukraine last week
asked Apple CEO Tim Cook
to ban Russia from using the
company's products and services
in response
to their attack on Ukraine.
Well, if being the only country
whose messages in the group chat
are green
doesn't force Russia
to surrender,
I don't know what will.
[ Russian accent ]
This is embarrassment.
We are only green.
No one even read these texts.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
The Senate last night failed
to pass the Women's Health
Protection Act,
and West Virginia Senator Joe
Manchin voted with Republicans.
Okay, how many times does
someone have to vote
with Republicans before
you consider him a Republican?
It's kind of like saying
Keith Richards played
with the Rolling Stones again.
Yeah,
'cause he's a Rolling Stone.
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi told
reporters yesterday
that Congress will support
"whatever it is"
the Ukraine needs amid Russia's
invasion of the country.
Well, unless
it's universal healthcare,
in which case there's all --
there's a copay, it's a mess.
New Orleans held its first
full-scale
Mardi Gras celebration today
since 2020, when
the coronavirus pandemic hit,
but required masks
in indoor public spaces.
Still, men were throwing beads
and yelling,
"Show us your chin!"
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Pig Day.
[ Cheering and applause ]
"When isn't it?" asked an --
What is wrong with you?
[ Laughter ]
Why are you cheering for it
like you even knew
it was a thing?
I don't understand
that reaction.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
If you cared so much,
why didn't you know?
[ Light laughter ]
I'm gonna tell the joke now,
alright?
[ Chuckles ]
I told you there should be
a National Pig Day!
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Pig Day.
"When isn't it?"
asked an exhausted Charlotte.
[ Laughter ]
"This friendship is starting
to feel very one-sided."
It lost its momentum
a little bit
when everybody
lost their [bleep] minds
about National Pig Day.
[ Laughter ]
You know what else?
I bet someone here
had bacon this morning.
[ Laughter ]
On National Pig Day.
[ Chuckles ] You monsters.
In honor of St. Patrick's Day,
Dunkin' Donuts
is offering
a shamrock macchiato.
In a related story, Italy
has declared war on Ireland.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Dunkin' Donuts is offering
a shamrock macchiato,
which is green
and features Irish cream flavor.
So, look for that
on a sidewalk near you.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
last night delivered
his first
State of the Union address
and Chuck Schumer could not
figure out when to clap.
[ Booing ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-The American Rescue Plan
helped working people.
-It's like every white guy
at a hip hop show.
[ Laughter ]
"You're clapping
on the ones and threes,
Richard!"
[ Laughter ]
During President Biden's
State of the Union address
last night,
several members of Congress
wore blue and yellow
in solidarity with Ukraine,
though I'm not sure everybody
understood the assignment.
[ Laughter ]
During last night's speech,
Republican Congresswomen
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Lauren Boebert heckled
and booed President Biden
on several occasions.
In their defense,
he is, technically,
the manager.
[ Hesitant laughter ]
And that, technically,
was a joke.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Technically.
[ Laughter ]
During President Biden's
State of the Union address
last night,
he accidentally said "Iranian,"
instead of "Ukrainian."
[ Laughter ]
Well,
in a speech where he had
to pronounce Volodymyr Zelenskyy
and Ketanji Brown Jackson,
something had to give.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According to a new poll,
71% of Americans
who watched President Biden's
State of the Union address
had a positive reaction
to the speech,
but let's be honest --
everyone who would've had
a negative reaction
was watching "Yellowstone."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
New York has the highest
median rent price
for a one-bedroom apartment
in the country.
Well, yeah, but it's all
about location, location...
[ Train screeching, rumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
...location.
And, finally,
Major League Baseball
announced yesterday
that they are
postponing their
March 31st Opening Day
and canceling
the first two series
of regular season baseball,
after the league could not reach
a bargaining agreement
with its players' union,
which is bad news for the Mets
because the regular season is
the only one they got.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Defense officials in Ukraine
have warned that the Kremlin
could be using deepfake videos
to spread misinformation
to Russians.
Okay. I knew Putin didn't have
an Iron Man suit.
[ Laughter ]
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
suggested in a court filing
yesterday that it has evidence
that former President Trump and
his campaign tried to illegally
obstruct Congress' counting of
electoral votes.
Yeah, we know.
[ Laughter ]
Watching the House investigate
this thing is like watching
"The Office"
with your grandmother.
"I think there's a spark
between Jim and that Pam."
"Yeah, Grandma, it's Season 6."
[ Laughter ]
A bipartisan group of
Congressional lawmakers is
calling on President Biden to
ban Russian oil and gas imports
amid the country's invasion
of Ukraine.
The bill has support from
both sides of the aisle
and the aisle.
[ Laughter ]
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
yesterday told several students
standing behind him at an indoor
event that they did not need to
wear face masks and said,
"Honestly, it's not doing
anything and we've got to stop
with this COVID theater."
Although for people who moved
from New York to Florida
during the pandemic, "That's the
only theater they have left."
[ Laughter ]
"Can you believe what they call
bagels down there?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm doing the Gilded Age
New York.
[ Laughter ]
"You call this a subway?"
Authorities in Germany yesterday
reportedly seized
a Russian billionaire's
$600 million mega yacht.
Said the billionaire,
"Oh, no, my backup yacht."
[ Laughter ]
Nike announced this week that
it's temporarily closing
its online store in Russia.
Apparently, it was giving Putin
some bad ideas.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
Luxury brand Bulgari said
this week that its sales
have increased
since the Ukrainian invasion
as wealthy Russians are buying
jewelry amid a collapse
of Russia's currency.
On the plus side, it does make
oligarchs easier to spot.
[ Laughter ]
A crown?
IKEA has announced it will
temporarily pause manufacturing
and retail operations
in Russia and Belarus
due to the invasion of Ukraine,
while IKEA in Ukraine is opening
their doors to Russian soldiers
and hoping they can't find
their way out.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon confirmed yesterday that
it plans to shut down
all of its physical bookstores.
They're getting back to doing
what originally
made them successful --
putting physical bookstores
out of business.
[ Laughter ]
A JetBlue pilot blew twice the
legal limit on a breathalyzer
yesterday after being removed
from the cockpit of a plane.
They were immediately suspicious
since the flight was Delta.
[ Laughter ]
What are you doing in here?
"Oh, let's get this puppy
in the air!
[ Laughter ]
Where are we headed?!"
Tomorrow is National Sons Day.
Said dads, "What did I get you?
What did I get you?
How about a roof over your head,
wiseguy?
What did I get you?"
[ Laughter ]
Really good dad.
And finally, New York Governor
Kathy Hochul yesterday unveiled
plans to permanently allow bars
and restaurants to offer
to-go alcoholic drinks.
So say hello to New York City's
newest mascot,
Martini Rat.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
"Well, they certainly don't have
that in Florida, do they?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no, Slurpee Rat.
That's the best
they can do there."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]